my head feels like a bunch of monkeys
fighting over a bucket of marbles my
mental struggles while debating movie
rankings on sin caste somehow makes its
way into this episode rather than panic
Cheryl managed to retrieve an air horn
and mace from her bag well keeping a
level enough head to converse with the
assailants show we'll go back to having
Cheryl being oblivious idiot after this
impressive display and that is not okay
also pop quiz is Cheryl a singing be
about to sneeze see prepping for a pizza
slice or D screaming for her life the
correct answer is a B or C as there is
no way that is an accurate depiction of
screaming for your life like the time
her Ocelot was sick both moaning an
ocelot in New York City is totally
illegal also illegal puppet shows weird
right although you seem to be able to
keep your eyes open wide even after
having them down with mace no boxes but
do you need a witness to your crime one
who can identify the van possibly the
license plate and the escape route
because that is what you have leaving
Cheryl behind because this guy I mean
the animators took the time to draw him
and have him walk up behind Cheryl and
we never see him again now I will spend
the rest of the episode creating a
dramatic backstory for Austin who
forever regrets pretending to drop his
smartphone so we could avoid being named
as a witness in the police report if his
family finds out he is in New York
they'll want him to stop by the M&M
store and that place is filled with
cheap chocolate and wasted dreams this
is a way better excuse than the trained
dwarf
my last name isn't Gimple like it says
on my w-4 this ends up being a fun
reveal that Cheryl is ridiculously rich
but as paranoid and money-hungry as
Malory is not to mention this is
supposed to be a top-notch spy agency
how has this identity cover-up not been
revealed before not apparently slavery
was pretty awesome prove it what's to
prove it's free labor Jesus you guys I'm
kind of freaking out do you mind if I
glue up it's your house it's totally
within Cheryl's character but drinking
glue was a sin right
Oh your family feud I am literally wet
with jealousy Lana just a cartoon lono
is just a cartoon Lana's just a cartoon
you got to get some tree branches or a
tire swing or something in there because
he is desperate for stuff to play with
because Archer have actual concern for
the Ocelot the only if we come for
Cheryl's surprise reveal but we leave
with the knowledge that the writers had
no [ __ ] clue what to do with Archer in
this episode so they
had him love a cat hardwood floors and a
wild cat with claws this is absolutely a
sense
so I guess this light is green because
this car goes through but then why would
this light appear red and why is this
car suddenly moving through when no
light has changed does this how New York
intersections work no this is how lazy
animation works Safety's off barn
perhaps take partial responsibility here
considering you handed it to him that
way great one sec what are you doing
tell you what I'm not doing Lana is
negotiating with a goddamn cyborg just a
voice modulator
robotic voice modulation would not only
be covered in spy 101 it would be a very
common audio experience during any
negotiation there is ZERO transfer juror
would believe a cyborg was on the line
and that's a shame because it sounds
like it could be a really fun pot also
why do they need so many [ __ ] maps in
a room with floor-to-ceiling monitors
that can easily show a map and zoom in
on any part of the world this episode
released in [ __ ] 2011 he's
seriously saying they still buy into
this whole dial tone sounds after you
hang up both this equipment and a cell
phone
you idiots this isn't Cheryl Todd's a
team of masked men were sent to retrieve
Cheryl tunt and nobody knew what she
looked like nobody on the retrieval team
had any sort of visual aid to help them
differentiate Cheryl from any woman in
all of New York that's what I've been
trying to tell ya between this little
gals love taps seriously maybe see if
your daddy will give you a roll of
nickels a few archer episodes have
passed without a sin removal for the
awesomeness that is Pam so I'll just
take care of that now how do you think I
paid for college does this flashback
assume that Pam kept her earrings on
while she was whipping ass who wears
earrings during a fight that is a lobe
liability alo bility I said also why
isn't Pam shirtless later she strips off
her top to attack old lady Archer
indicating that when that was down she's
shirtless so we should be seeing blurred
out Pam nipples right now which reminds
me that nipple inequality on screen is
just a bunch of bull
free the nipple IRS Jesus how many Irish
kings are there I know Cheryl is
supposed to be an idiot but she's also
rich so she knows exactly who the IRS is
I can't say that with a straight face
Archer and Rainey are the kind of people
who can hear a cat licking their ass
from across the house but can't hear an
engine or the sound of metal scraping
metal from a few feet away I hate those
kind of people they spent kidnapped
ourselves no I don't
even for you considering everyone will
find out shortly the threat is real why
is the scene or show has time for this
you pick this time drop your weapons or
she dies Oh seriously I get the Pam's
upset but this part really has nothing
to do with her I have two assets they're
trying to protect and their training
would not have them immediately put
their guns down once threatened everyone
important survives this bullet bro how
would he even hear Sheryl screaming over
all the gunfire Jesus archers got some
very selective hearing in this episode
just fall off oh shut up
mr. Pam's not worth it how does she know
what he said when he said the phrase in
question earlier
Lana it's not worth it it's just bad
yeah so Pam wouldn't have heard anything
then you stupid a-holes shoot a jillion
stupid a-hole bullets at me but the
bullets graduated from the zorg school
of convenient target discovery no one
was ever in real danger Pam geez Old
English font nip my thoughts exactly
nope on this episode for reminding me of
my hatred for animated button madness do
you know how many time Cheryl buttons
have moved on her shirt when the episode
first started there was no upper button
then we see what I assume was the
correct placement for her buttons which
was on the right side I could let that
go and do a flip to our left side
moments later then back to a right side
suddenly they migrate up her shirt down
her shirt all the way up by your collar
poof the top button goes invisible
moments later reappears now the
animators give zero because there are
buttons on both sides of her shirt which
is one of the dumbest things I've ever
seen back to the top missing altogether
that's finally when the end the episode
with the buttons clearly on the opposite
side of her goddamn bubblegum pink petal
pink shirt
well I killed all the old merch in a
ritualistic bonfire them from the ashes
Rose a new merch enterprise hahaha
grab a cloaca cast a stone or do the
cliche fan thing and sip yummy out of a
sexy mug and a code ding for a discount
because you were amazing fans and we
appreciate you now stop and go get your
sweet new swag link below or find our
store at cinemas INSCOM then he's all
like you gotta go before my roommate
gets home and I'm like yadda yadda yadda
I'm really tired today what do you think
she was tired from well obviously the
yada yada first get Pam back but and
bring me some stuff to do and watch your
March scream and will somebody answer
the damn phone for once in their life
look in your way Brett to 60 to 80 and
Jackson makes three cameras are your mom
blew up Ricky so you're crazy
this is agent lana kane and you are
myself he did you disappear hey one
minute you were there the next minute
you were gone did you run through the
woods
relax they can't risk killing Carol but
I think that's great